the u.s is here it's hearing another
grim milestone in the coronavirus
pandemic 600
000 deaths nationwide even though trends
are moving in the right direction the
biden administration is reminding
everyone to get vaccinated michael
george has the latest
with daily new covet 19 cases in
michigan going from a flood
to a trickle the state plans to fully
reopen on july 1st
but experts warn that low case counts
during the summer months could trick
people into a false sense of security
it is somewhat seasonal and so i would
say
next fall we could see another tick
up in covid cases in sacramento
california governor gavin newsom helped
select
15 lucky residents to win 50 thousand
dollars a piece
in the state's vaccine lottery this is
all about raising awareness about
encouraging others
that are on the fence to get vaccinated
but even with california planning to
fully reopen its economy and
dropping mass mandates on june 15
newsome warned that the virus is not
taking the summer off
this san francisco restaurant tour says
he and his employees
are keeping their face coverings on for
the time being i don't mind wearing the
mask
i think it's a good practice until
we literally defeat the pandemic if
that's possible
in south carolina dan tompkins spent
nearly 300 days in the hospital
and rehabilitation after a close call
with covet 19.
all i want to do is just get home
i got a little puppy about this tall i
haven't seen in 10 months
that i want to hold in my lap this
afternoon and my father
and tell her how much i love her this
week watkins got his wish
with plenty of love affection and licks
michael george cbs news